je sais pas ce qui m'arrive depuis
maintenant deux mois
ma vie est devenue un enfer je suis
comme traqué par elle j'ai d'abord pensé
que ça pouvait m'être utile mais non
comédiens les avis souvenez-vous j'ai
tout vous expliquer un problème que
j'avais et que beaucoup de gens vont à
savoir la rage de jeux vidéo et depuis
que je joue à fraudeurs soient encore
pire qu'avant depuis deux mois j'ai un
problème colossal mais mon gars tu vois
et sa foi 10 le problème ils étaient
choqués que je touche un objet
métallique je me prends une décharge mon
gars mais comme la clôture qui gardent
les vaches quoi et alors au début ça
m'amuse et je me dis waouh
[ __ ] je besoin de gros coup tu es au
bout de deux heures tu en as marre quand
je lance la caméra je me prends un coup
de jus avec le cash que coca cola d'une
grande qualité je me suis même pris un
coup tu dans l'oreille la dernière fois
bon ça c'était juste parce que le casque
et un peu chelou qu'un jour une porte ça
ça devient ton pire ennemi le bouton
pour appeler l'ascenseur désolé je crie
mais franchement pour une fois c'est
justifié là vraiment je ne sais pas si
certains trouveront ce problème mais ça
fait deux mois que je suis électrique je
pensais au début j'avais vraiment un
super pouvoir je faisais [ __ ] je vais
résilier mon contrat avec edf vas-y je
peux créer moi-même électricité juin ou
fin octobre
norges me l'apprendre juste électricité
jeunes a créé pas c'est juste un pouvoir
nul voilà où tu es un peu électrique
mais pas trop je me suis alors mis à
développer des techniques pour ne plus
être surpris par le fait de recevoir un
code etc tricité en touchant quelque
chose technique numéro une
il faut un pull ce qui n'est pas le cas
voilà effets spéciaux cas pour demain
tous bien blanche ne doit surtout pas
entrer en contact avec cet objet tu vas
donc d'ouvrir avec le coude et perdent
tous tes amis qui te prendre on pourra
profond de murray mais c'est là
qu'intervient la deuxième technique que
j'ai mise au point tel que tu utilises
ponctuée d'un tee shirt à manches
courtes
la surprise c'est la pire de toute carte
une passe plus pour un demeuré
mais pour un profond demeurait à
tendances psychopathes tu viens pas non
je vais passer par la fenêtre dans le
doute les gens me fuient ils ont peur de
moi je sais très bien que si certains
d'entre vous ont ce problème vous avez
développé les deux mêmes techniques le
coude ou le petit coup qui fait que tu
seras moins surpris par la décharge
je me suis même mis à avoir mal à la
tête au moment où je te fais un objet
métallique parce que je me concentre
pour pas être surpris par la décharge je
pense que c'est un problème
d'installation et edf
on va les appeler
[Musique]
non merci de ta té votre client votre
lecture
bonjour je vous appelle parce que je
pense qu'il ya un problème avec vos
installations dès que je touche un objet
en métal je me prend une grosse décharge
voilà donc c'est désagréable j'ai fait
plusieurs malaises déjà et ça me
tiraille depuis deux mois environ quand
je touche une poignée un pc n'importe
quoi un objet métallique je me prends
une décharge
oui déjà oui m'a dit que tout était
normal donc souvent pas trop mais c'est
comme les tristes et statique d'un coup
je me prends un petit à un petit coup
quoi et des amis m'ont dit que ça venait
de chez vous d'accord bon et du coup
est-ce que vous avez des solutions s qui
éventuellement si je mets mes mains dans
des chaussettes pour toucher les objets
métalliques j'aurais plus problème
d'accord plutôt socket ou chaussettes de
ski du coup d'accord alors ce sera des
petites socquettes bas merci merci de
votre aide c'est hyper sympa au revoir
mais [ __ ] mais tu vois j'ai passé la
fin de la vie avec des choses c'est
thomas mais il va pas bien ce gars bon
j'en ai parlé autour de moi
bruce d'y penser vis le même calvaire
legrand jd vis le même calvaire skis et
l'association pour aider les gens qui
soient il trop occupée régulièrement
tout le temps association des gens qui
se prennent des décharges quand il
touche un objet métallique
j'arrête pas de prendre des coups de
décharges électriques incessantes sur
tout ce que je touche je suis électrique
le phénomène foudre foudre version pdf
ça sert d'abord est ce que quelqu'un un
jour aura une réponse
[Musique]
un problème se pose et ouais j'ai hâte
de prendre des décharges bas figure toi
que quand tu prends des décharges c'est
à cause de l'électricité statique et
d'ailleurs ces décharges porte un nom on
les appelle des décharges
électrostatiques bon ce qu'il faut c'est
se rappeler comment ces foutus un atom
il ya un noyau composé de neutrons et de
protons et des électrons qui gravitent
autour de son noyau vrai tu vois electra
et le truc c'est que lors de chaque
contact lors de chaque frottement avec
une surface quand ensuite un pull quand
tu frottes une serviette quand une
marche pieds nus sur de la moquette ou
quand enfile un slip en ligne bref ne
dis pas que ça arrive jamais eh bien
parfois en arrache de ces électrons
alors l'électricité s'accumulent dans
ton corps il devient plus riche en
électrons il est donc chargé
négativement et ensuite lorsque tu
touches une surface chargée positivement
il ya ce petit choc électrique que toi
tu semble ressentir assez souvent ce
choc correspond au transfert d'électrons
d'un milieu à un autre alors j'avoue ça
pique un petit peu on peut pas y faire
grand chose lorsqu'il ya un transfert
d'électrons d'un milieu chargées
négativement à un milieu chargée
positivement car des charges
c'est précisément ça que tu ressembles
bon et dans l'ensemble pourquoi ces
tarifs surtout depuis deux mois la
réponse l'hiver ça a plus tendance à
arriver en hiver qu'en été parce qu en
hiver les conditions météorologiques
favorisent cette circulation électrique
donc on a plus tendance à se prendre des
coups durs voilà s'allumer salut neumann
tu viens effectivement d'éclairer ma
lanterne pour tendue dans un camion non
bellamy serpent la vidéo si vous vivez
le même calvaire que moi n'hésitez pas
aimer les vidéos walo faut soutenir
parce qu elle pas de solution de manière
adf mandat conseil mais j'suis pas très
chauds pécho avec des chaussettes aux
mains ces stars foule était fort merci
notre mal dans ses explications
bon la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il ya pas
de solution mais la bonne nouvelle c'est
que maintenant je comprend ce qui se
passe quand je me prends un coup de jus
cio va durer encore trois ans parce que
j'ai peur d'appuyer sur l'écran pour
arrêter le rec jean phlippe aujourd'hui
je me suis pas trop pris encore je pense
qu'il ya vraiment une chance aux gens
présents attendent du coup j'ai peur je
ne parlais pas attention on ne l'arrêté
c'est bon je suis pas pris plus tard
[Musique]
ça